these are the pathfinders one of the
british army's
most elite units trained to operate
behind enemy lines
and they almost never allow themselves
to be filmed
they're the tip of the spear parachuting
in days ahead of the main force
and often operating completely alone
we spent time with them on exercise in
ukraine
in russia's backyard how do you get in
what are the tactics that you use to get
into
what are often areas of of instability
so i mean in the context of an airborne
mission or an airborne operation
like this we would parachute ahead of of
the main body
um either in employing a high altitude
high opening jump or high altitude low
opening jump
um in order to covertly insert
um most likely at night in order to
remain undetected
from the enemy the pathfinders work
covertly
securing the ground and establishing a
drop zone
48 hours later hundreds of british
paratroopers from 16 air assault brigade
have flown in
it is the largest british parachute drop
in decades
they jump with ukrainian airborne forces
creating an image that won't go
unnoticed in moscow
it is pretty tense um that's why it's
important i think that we've come here
to show that we
support the ukrainians um it won't go
unnoticed
i don't think so no i certainly hope it
doesn't go unnoticed
that's the point yes um
this might be an exercise for the
british but ukraine is a country still
very much a war they're fighting russian
forces in the east
and crimea is only two hours drive from
here
tensions along the border are getting
worse
do you think the russian threat is
growing even greater
how do you characterize it right now
it's becoming stronger now that russia
is trying to deploy
large battle groups along the ukraine
border on a permanent basis
it's not just russia neighboring belarus
is also uneasy
after last month's disputed elections
alexander
lukashenko the president under pressure
has accused nato of massing troops on
belarus's border
it is a distraction technique a
desperate attempt to cling onto power
but images like this of british
paratroopers landing in ukraine
can be spun many ways alastair bunker
sky news
in ukraine